[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
how's it going
hello it's bit I don't know if anyone
knows but it's Billy's birthday today
the 28th of August it's his birthday as
well what's your name
happy birthday Eagle another Virgo
another vertical but one who used to
look after Frankenstein oh is that right
wow
he has a Frankenstein tattoo I'd set a
tattoo this morning
or finished off my tattoo this morning
yeah how's it looking I don't know
because it's all over my back do you
have a look at it is it scabby you tell
me
this is gonna be good for radio
oh it's lovely look at that
look everyone
whoa
[Applause]
wow you're looking good yeah well I'm
cutting I'm cutting you're like American
psychos yeah I know you've been
you've been bulking I've been bulking
how's the bolt going it's great man it's
just a lot of eating and what I've done
is I've taken the gym work out of it
right which makes it even more fun
and is that that's that's a science
thing or is that just a youth thing
that's just a laziness thing though
right that's just been incredibly lazy
right I will occasionally still do a
squat good
yeah balkan's quite difficult the
cutting's difficult too so I'm doing
like less eating and more gyming and
you're doing Maureen and less Jimmy
we're going to meet in the middle
all the way around by which team I'll be
800 pounds and you'll be the size of a
sparrow
I mean I'm surprised that all of us
weren't 800 pounds uh on Friday night
because we had what was it a 12 course
dinner
Toronto's a good place isn't it
[Music]
oh look at that little baby over there
there's two little
Bears little babies over there little
Dom and Little Billy yeah
they turned up in every town
hey no it's it's brilliant Queen
Street's good doesn't it you could walk
up and down there for days just so
entertaining I walked up Green Street
right and I went to the art gallery
lovely and then I walked back down and
it was as if they had exchanged all the
stores
like I went in all the stores on the way
up and then on the way down it felt like
it was all new stores it's weird and
Billy said this very very mature thing
at dinner
uh no he did you get you're becoming
much more of an adult in your old age
now
um we were catching up the four of us
and I said how was the art gallery and
Billy said oh it's great but he said you
know the thing with art gallery is this
you can only really take in about six to
eight paintings and then it's just too
much you know so he said I went in there
and spent time with a few paintings and
then when it got to a point where I was
being overly stimulated I had to walk
out and I thought that's that's such a
grown-up way to approach an art gallery
I walk around going huh every room every
room every everybody I know most people
do don't you yeah especially one of the
big ones you know like the Louvre or
something and you want to see every
painting and and you can it's just a
blur isn't it so yeah if you're going in
our Gallery just pick eight paintings
and really have a look at them yeah give
them a really good look
um hey should we do
was that is that the way that you look
at pains
wow it's a real journey with you isn't
it
has done yeah it depends what the pain
is I looked at one and it was um Home
Service a very sad one no it was
biblical you know when King Herod oh you
told me about this this is going to
really bring down the mood but you know
King Herod said you know someday was
going to be born who was going to take
his power so he killed all the kids two
little babies over there don't point
over there over there
but I saw I saw it as it was a metaphor
for man sets for power oh is that right
that's what I thought right the things
you would do it'd be powerful would you
would do oh yeah yeah no I'm thinking of
taking over the world
peeling The Onion
hey should we do some housekeeping hold
on uh get your glasses out come on old
man now I've left my glasses oh no this
is gonna be an awful it's going to be
one-sided
[Music]
wow shall I read most of them can you
are you struggling yeah oh
lovely thank you thank you the lovely
Sandy lovely Sandy thank you
well I'll I'll start anyway this is a
question it seems that well almost all
of these questions have come from Canada
uh most of them from Toronto which is
great this is from nurisha in Toronto
who said to say I'm excited you come
into Toronto as an understatement I
suppose Suite if you guys were UFC
fighters
[Laughter]
what song would you enter the ring to
wow oh that's good good question isn't
it
who's had good walk-in
um didn't Tyson oh Tyson's was just a
sound just a noise Mike Tyson used to
come on to like
like a drone yeah it was terrifying
a few people have come out to like LL
Cool J's Mama Said Knock You Out which
is quite cool that was quite cool all
right cool yeah yesterday during the
convention you brought a little speaker
didn't you I did and you played the same
song
over and over
not only like all day which was like 10
hours but then when we got in the car to
go back to the hotel he put it back on
yeah
and Elijah said this morning as we were
coming in and you weren't in the car
because you were getting tattooed he
said I think it's when I went back on in
the car
it got painful yeah what was that song
Oh beautiful Harry Styles as it was
beautiful song you should come on to
that yeah uh that would be a great one
no he's he's great Harry Styles he's so
positive with his sound and his Vibe and
the reason why I was playing it for the
boys while we were doing this photo
shoot was at the at the panel that we
did last night we had like a little
dance party and I wanted the three
fellas to know the song so well that
they could kind of Boogie to the Beats I
was just like let's just play it move to
the beat we could have performed it
could have put all the instruments do
you remember I mean I am like that I'm a
little upset well I get very obsessed
about stuff but I remember in New
Zealand uh Billy and I were taking a
road trip uh while we were doing one of
the kind of locations and I was
listening to Hallelujah the Leonard
Cohen cover by Jeff Buckley all day and
Billy like had to say to me can't keep
playing that because I love that song
and he's now making me start to hate
that song and I was like yeah but when I
really like something I just want to do
it over and over and over again he was
like that's great but I don't so Play
the album instead but anyway uh songs
come on so you know what I'd like to
come on to um just like juxtapose it a
little bit I'd like to come on to the
Friendship Onion song so come out you
know boxing gloves on strip to the waist
maybe like boiled up yeah
that would scale them what about you I
would say I was in New York recently and
I went to see Rage Against the Machine
wow they reformed and it was amazing
incredible I would come out to build it
in your head oh yeah
one of the great debut albums of all
time in rock music that you should have
seen that life oh yeah the singer had
hurt his leg
and uh so he couldn't he couldn't jump
we couldn't walk he had to be carried
out and he sat in a box at the front of
the stage while the rest of the band
played but I kind of liked that because
he was just sitting there you know doing
the lyrics and they could do big
close-ups of his faces it was brilliant
what a concert
what's better than finding quality
candidates well finding them instantly
for a powerful hiring partner you need
indeed indeed is the hiring platform
where you can attract interview and hire
all in one place don't spend hours on
multiple job sites looking for
candidates with the right skills when
you can do it all with indeed find Top
Talent fast with indeed Suite of
powerful hiring tools like indeed
instant match assessments and virtual
interviews you hate waiting indeed U.S
data shows over 80 percent of indeed's
employers find quality candidates whose
resumes on indeed matches their job
description the moment they sponsor a
job Indeed is fantastic with instant
match as soon as you sponsor a post you
get a short list of quality candidates
whose resume is on indeed match your job
description and you can invite them to
apply right away indeed no knows that
when you're doing everything for your
company you can't afford to overspend On
hiring visit indeed.com onion to start
hiring now just go to indeed.com onion
indeed.com
onion terms and conditions apply cost
per application pricing not available
for everyone need to hire
you need indeed
well I just love that sound because
that's the sound of a seal oh yes that's
the sound of a seal on Shopify another
sale on Shopify the all-in-one Commerce
platform to start run and grow your
business Shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big
businesses so now upstarts or startups
and established businesses all the lake
can sail everywhere synchronize online
in-person sales and effortlessly stay
informed scaling your business is a
journey of Endless Possibilities believe
me look at this podcast we started
selling tea shops now we've got hats
mugs and water bottles I hope you've got
all that mounts by the way and we're not
stop in there because success is a
million Milestones on a forever evolving
path I love how Shopify has the tools
and resources that make it easy for any
business to succeed from down the street
to around the globe like our podcast
Shopify Powers millions of businesses
from for sale to full scale reach
customers online and across social
networks with an ever-growing Suite of
Channel Integrations and apps including
Facebook Instagram Tick Tock Pinterest
and more again and saves as you grow
with detailed reporting of conversion
rates profit margins and Beyond but it's
more than a store Shopify grows with you
this is possibility powered by Shopify
and go to shopify.com all lowercase for
a free 14-day trial and get full access
to shopify's entire Suite of features
grow your business with Shopify today go
to shopify.com onion right now
shopify.com
hey bills do the next one right you're
edit them
I didn't clean my glasses just to let
you know you never do
I can see past it I mean it's kind of
like those little clouds everywhere
quite like it Olivia from Toronto
is Olivia in here Hello Olivia I love
you what a lovely t-shirt she just
popped up there did you see that it was
good it's like a Jack In The Box
uh we know from the podcast that you
both love to read and as any reader
knows you can sometimes get into a
reading Funk when you don't read for a
while so my question is what is a book
that has helped you get out of the
reading Funk before good question
look at that
um by optico the professional and
glasses do they sponsor the show what
are you doing it's a cleaning way for an
optical electronic surfaces what okay
um I've actually been in a little bit of
a reading Funk during covid
I think I like fried my attention span
because instead of you know I'm usually
watching films most night and have no
problem sitting down for a couple of
hours watching a film and I found myself
doing that really irksome thing of
enjoying a film and going oh gosh this
film's really great I'm having a really
great time watching it instead of just
watching the film I'm like telling
people that I'm watching a film that I
liked you know so I think
I fry my attention span and the thing
that um has slightly brought me back was
um I've been reading where the crawdads
sing is that right I've not seen the
film
but I'm reading that book that has a
really beautiful very simple connection
to Nature
foreign
oh nice
I can see him he's quite beautiful
so I think that that book's really have
you read that bill I haven't read that I
haven't read that young lady living in
the kind of
swamp lands and just you know not very
well read or has never gone to school
but her understanding of the natural
world is profound it's really beautiful
so yeah
I'll see that thing of yours that you
write to people and know that I think
that's what the word was mean when you
said when you watch a movie and you oh
yeah I'm having an ace yeah I think it's
I think it's because of your Lust For
Life Tom oh okay and I think when you
see something that you like for instance
the Harry Style song you have to share
it I want everyone to like it everybody
like this as much as I like it and
there's a lot of things in the world and
you want to do them all
yeah today yeah so I think it's a nice
thing I wouldn't oh well thanks I think
it's lovely yeah I think I sometimes
overwhelm you don't you because I every
time I see you say have you seen that
you should see it and you're like that's
too many that's too many things 20
things you bought me eight books and I
find when I read uh I find kind of like
Queen Street I feel that as I'm reading
people are putting extra chapters into
the book
you know I put it down and then I pick
it back up and I'm I'm no further
towards the end of the book as I was
well I don't know if you know but I used
to be a book binder
um when I was younger and I used to make
books and
really as a book binder you're setting
up giant machines that make paperbacks
it sounds romantic and it sounds like
you're working with leather and and
making kind of spells books with spells
yeah yeah but you're not I mean most of
the time you're setting up giant
machines that go so I just used to grab
any book that I was making and I'd read
it but as I was reading it I would read
page one page two and then I'd rip it
out and I'd throw it away because you
know it's just off the machine I didn't
buy it or anything and then I'd read
four or five and I threw it away and
throw it away and the book gets smaller
and smaller until all you had was a page
and you'd finish that throw it away and
it was gone
right and it's a good way to read a book
because you see it getting smaller
but in the house as I say Dom likes to
buy me a book a day and it's hard to
keep up with that sort of you know
number of books so I feel like I've been
reading the same books for months so I'm
I'm probably in a funk as well but in a
strange sort of I read every day but
somehow somebody's sticking an extra
chapters so for me what I would do and I
like to do this sometimes is buy a book
of short stories
if you've got a good novel or a good
book of short stories I think they
really stick with you you know and it's
a good way of like I can read the whole
story tonight you know it's maybe only
10 pages or something so I would do that
I read one it was short stories from New
York I can't remember who wrote it but
Google that you'll find something you've
been consistently reading that Bill
Bryson book that we both love called the
body it was the is there any one fact
that has blown your mind more than
anything else up to now about that book
this is a brilliant book that Dawn got
me and uh and it's all about the human
body and every chapter is like maybe
eyes and then
mouse sure
lungs toes yeah that kind of thing
pancreas but that's one of those books
because you have to come to an end of
that because there's only so much of a
human body
before it becomes something else shoes
you you run a body don't you you do yeah
so uh but there's been a quite a few
things in that that have blown my mind
one being there whatever you weigh
so if you we you know 15 Stone
whatever that is well 150 pounds yeah
that's 150 pounds
more than half of that isn't you
yeah I know
more than half of that is things that
are living on you or in you
that is not you
yeah so who are you who am I I'm
straight away I'm half the man I thought
I wanted
I mean just things loving on you yeah
yeah all those things please
worms yeah flukes flukes and flax and
tapeworms and stuff eating you and Betsy
you and eating your poo ah and eating
things off your eyebrows yeah yeah
I like that too
there's a chapter about the mouth and
specifically the tongue and I think one
of the ones that stood out the most for
me which you don't tend to think about
this that much but he mentions the the
tongue which obviously cannot see is
able to detect a tiny fragment of a
broken piece of a toothpick and a
massive mouthful of food eat the food be
able to isolate that tiny piece of a
toothpick and bring it to the front of
your mouth consistently over and over
again to alert the brain hey we have an
alien thing in here that we want to take
out and I remember just thinking what an
incredible organ that is to be able to
do that and to know this is you know
vegetables and food that we're eating
this is a piece of wood maybe so just
check it out
and then you're breaking out no no
that's just the overly cooked piece of
food so I'm gonna eat that but the
tongue will go well have a look have a
look have a look amazing and sometimes
the tongue will tell you things like I
was down in Mexico a couple of weeks ago
and matung said that oyster's not good
and your brain said I'm gonna eat it
anyway
and then my stomach said oh you should
have listened to the tongue
foreign
[Laughter]
it wasn't like just a bit I was like
I feel old sort of weird and I thought I
don't know what's going on
and uh apparently that's part of if
you're a really bad oyster which I knew
was a bad oyster winner it was expensive
Dom give us another one come on well
let's do one last one because we're
gonna try and get into a tongue yeah
well should we ask you should we see if
someone wants to have two questions here
two questions from the audience we're
definitely gonna have our friend here
because you came to my panel the other
day and had your hand up for like half
an hour so can we ask this lovely young
lady here uh what's your name where do
you come from
um Dom I love you hi oh whoa thank you
I'm sat here next to building is that
why you is that why you choose her well
she wasn't my panel uh yesterday and I
had a hand up for like a good 25 minutes
and unfortunately we didn't get around
to you so I'm sorry about that but here
we go today I heard today it came back
for you I'm cool but um I just wanted to
ask like when you guys first met like
how did how did you guys first meet how
did you come best friends eat that first
story of you guys
Dominic darling
I was in the country of New Zealand
preparing to play in a movie called The
Lord of the Rings
I had flown to New Zealand to also be in
the same movie The Lord of the Rings and
I'd been there for a little bit Leonard
hope you saw a fence and paddle boats
and all that and uh Dom was working on a
a movie I think or a TV show and Euro
and um couldn't make it uh as quickly as
though so he was about a week later and
me and Sean
and Elijah and Orlando had all been
there and I knew that the guy who was
Queen Mary was coming in that week and I
I was slightly worried because I thought
I've got a lot to do with this guy and I
like all these other guys already so I'm
kind of worried this is going to be the
one guy that I don't like
and then we've got like three years of
that but he came in and we were in the
wardrobe department and he said oh don't
monaghan's arrived so I ran out and we
had a hug and a chat and we went out and
played some poo that that night and we
had a great night and I thought oh
that's all right then he seems okay yeah
okay since thanks
I was quite jet-lagged and I think I was
probably a little overrod by all two
obviously you know meeting all the boys
at the same time but I knew that seeing
Billy was going to be key because
obviously Marion Pippin spent a huge
amount of time together and yeah just
just very kind of effortless right I
think there's there's kind of an
interesting thing that hello ladies in
the bat with fantastic costumes on well
done well done you entertainment teach
to make two hats makes you half an hour
late for the friendship
I think there's something to be said for
this kind of like British thing
obviously Billy being Scottish myself
being English in in the sense of like
we'll we all know what it means and how
the dynamic Works in a kind of Pub
situation by the time you're 18 or over
there's I'm sure you guys obviously know
being Canadians there's a there's a
connection between being British and
pubs and all that kind of stuff but you
know just that playful fun kind of
banter you know you have a drink you
play some cool there's jokes there's
little things going on we knew that
Billy and I had known that for you know
years before meeting each other in a
slightly different way that possibly
Elijah didn't know because Elijah's only
18 you've never been to a pub at that
point you know and and shown to a lesser
degree so with two Brits together you
get this thing of the the kind of
playful light-hearted fun social thing
and that happened that was there
immediately yeah I think that just
that's a very merry and Pippin thing
just to be like are we okay in this
space yeah great let's have fun you know
that's that's what Marion Pippin do
they're obviously fully aware of the
seriousness of of the journey but like
you see them at eisengard they're like
well we're well fed we're safe three
bits here let's smoke pack weed and
drink some beer yeah yeah because you
know in a couple of days we may have to
be in a battle or and they know that but
they're like that doesn't mean to me
yeah we're not gonna drink and eat some
bad oysters yeah true
should we take one more question yeah
maybe do a tongue twister
who choose this young gentleman here
with a fantastic hoodie on now what's
your name and where are you from good
morning I'm Matt I'm from Leamington
it's a small town near the Detroit
border Leamington yeah
tomato town
Windsor yeah Windsor Robin yeah
Leamington leamington's near Windsor
okay yeah cool gotcha uh so I was
listening to the episode with lazy game
reviews and you were talking about
Canada and the provinces and it sounded
like you were a little bit confused we
we work so if my hand okay is Canada
okay
[Applause]
as he was happening where is Toronto
well we'll call this Southwestern
Ontario here the little that's Western
Ontario the tip of my thumb is
Leamington actually so I would I would
well Vancouver
uh like your middle name where's
Edmonton
I would go up from the thumb like just
keep going up from the thumb and maybe
get to that kind of like tendiny area
keep going up keep going up like yeah I
would say about that
[Music]
you know Billy's hand better yeah
yeah he knows my hand but the back of my
hand
no a word from our sponsor better help
it can be tough sometimes when you've
got a problem and you can't seem to find
a solution the more you think about the
problem the more you see the problem and
not the solution it can be really hard
to make your brain stay in that
problem-solving mode when you're faced
with a challenge in your life when you
do work out how you find your own
Solutions it can be one of the greatest
feelings ever a therapist can help you
become a better Problem Solver making it
easier to accomplish your goals no
matter how big they might be or small it
can help if you can become a good
Problem Solver and a therapist can
really help with that so if you're
thinking of giving therapy a try better
help is a great option it's convenient
it's accessible it's affordable and it's
entirely online you can get matched with
a therapist very quickly after you take
a brief survey and if you want you can
change your therapist at any time when
you want to become a better Problem
Solver therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com forward slash onion
that's betterhelp.com
onion and you will get 10 of your first
month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash onion
hey should we do a tongue twister yes we
don't even have a song for a tongue
twist to do we're gonna have to write a
jingle for a tongue twist yeah we'll do
that and maybe is there anyone out there
that thinks they're quite Adept at
tongue twisters that would like to
challenge billionites who are tongue
twist because we are fantastic as you'll
probably see I don't see that many hands
I don't see any hands going on to be
honest no one oh oh Billy Joel hey that
was the first hand up was over there
are you sure
okay a late a late lady in the Boba Fett
too right okay so
who's going first is it me I don't mind
what's your name and where'd you come
from my name is Jess and I'm from Guelph
which is like an hour away from here
wealth wealth oh well with a G yeah wow
well that sounds like Welsh doesn't it
does yeah or or Elvis
is there a way that we can put the
tongue there's the tongue twister up on
this on the screen there it's going to
be three times round
and when me and Dom do it what was your
name again sorry Jeff Jess I was so
taken by Guelph
two times around this when it's me and
my friend here on my right
see whether we do it right or wrong
three times in a row and then obviously
you're gonna have a go Jess so Billy do
you want dealer's Choice it's your
birthday I'll go first or you go first
it's up to you it's your birthday you go
first okay I have this I have the sheet
in front of me here all right
give us a three two one go ready
three two one go I slit the sheet the
sheet I slit on the slitted sheet I sit
I slit the sheet the sheet I slit on the
slitted sheet I sit I slit the sheet the
sheet I slit on the slitted sheet I sit
oh goodness yes yes thoughts Jess
thoughts
okay okay no issues oh what could I put
something forward here please did it
hear any point during that say the word
and
where's and
we'll do it again
I'm sorry Jess as well
my first time don't be like nice no no I
didn't even honestly I didn't even see
in the end all right here we go again
give us three two one go thank you
a three two one
once you go on the go okay because then
we'd have go and we did establish a go
and then it didn't happen she wanted to
go now three two one and then you go
okay thank you Jess hey Jess you're
becoming quite aggressive I love it hey
are we ready yes a three two one I slit
the sheet they sleep oh no no but we're
only calling that the first one because
the first one wasn't the first one right
yeah I'm ready
three two one I slit the sheet the sheet
I slipped and on the slitted sheet I sit
I slit the Sheep the Sheep I slit an on
this slitted sheet I sit I slit the
Sheep the sheet I slipped oh no that was
going so well wow no Dom please Focus I
got it I like pressure here we go
three two one I slit the sheet the sheet
I slipped and on the slitted sheet I sit
I slit the sheet the sheet I slipped and
on the slitted sheet I sit I slit the
sheet the sheet isolate and on the
slitted sheet I said
nicely
it's not easy that one you've seen that
I was doing some weird thing with my eye
there
slit the [ __ ] when did you see if your
mouth was getting wired all right became
a pirate during that one right I'm
giving you a three two one and no go
yeah let go NHS ready any mistake just
say no start over how fast were you 11
seconds 11 seconds that's very good
actually ready yes three two one I
slipped the sheet the sheet I slit and
on the slitted sheet I sit I slit the
sheet the sheet I slit and on the
slitted sheet I sit I slit the sheet the
[ __ ] I slit and on the slitted sheet I
sit
it's not over the moon about
yes
she might have done a little faster uh
well I I thought there was a little lack
of clarity if anyone else think that he
just slightly slipped at the end no are
you okay with it I mean look
okay you got two more girls let's go
again I think you can get it I think you
can get it in 10 seconds I've had a few
rounds so you can have yeah it's your
birthday yeah right it's my birthday for
goodness
ready yes
three two one I slipped the sheet the
sheet I slit and honestly sheet I said I
slipped the sheet the sheet I slit and
honestly sheet I said I slipped the
sheet the sheet I slid and on this
little cheat sheet I said well
[Applause]
you can have it because no I got tattoos
I [ __ ] have it because it's your
birthday right only because it's your
birthday I wasn't happy about the
clarification I wasn't but you can't
have it yes it's your birthday it's
perfect yeah give it to him come on you
win perfect I thought it was brilliant
it was absolutely brilliant are you
ready are you ready Jess you you've just
said three two one am I on go or am I go
you go on go we'd go three two one okay
ready
ready three two one I slipped the sheet
and oh sorry
three two one I slit the sheet the sheet
I slit and on the slitted sheet I sit I
slipped the sheet the sheet I slit and
on the slitted sheet I sit I slit the
sheet the sheet I slit and on the
sledded sheet I sit it's not ah it's not
bad I didn't think it was perfect you
want one more girl
there was a slutted sheet yes
which I'm not sure what that is I don't
know either are you ready I don't I
don't judge sheets no you no we
shouldn't we should never judge sheets
okay three two one I slipped the sheet
the sheet I slit and on the sledded
sheet I said the slit ice sheet
so what a shame no you did well you're
dead has anyone else that think they can
do better
that first hand went up over there was a
young lady here with the lovely special
thank you yes that was brilliant
right here we go
what's your name
and where do you come from hi hi oh
she's upstairs I can't see it though all
right okay you can come as close as you
want come on oh
[Music]
give yourself a nice view of the screen
yeah what's your name and where'd you
come from uh my name is Juliet and I'm
from Toronto oh hello Julia are you
ready
maybe all right Bill oh me okay give you
a three two one and then you just go
okay three two one I slit the sheet the
sheet I slit and on the slitted sheet I
said I slit the sheet the sheet I slid
and on the slitted sheet I said I slit
the sheet the sheet I slit and on the
slitted sheet I said whoa oh my God
fantastic work Julian fantastic well
done
well done hey Billy
it was brilliant but it was still a
second longer than me
the birthday boy hey we're almost
running out of time and you know what we
need to do now
Billy and Dom eat the world
we've we've brought together what we
hope is kind of a classic piece of um
certainly Canadian if not totally wrong
so would you say torontorian is that how
you guys would say it
torontonian a couple of babies answered
over there thank you thank you
um do you have any other plates any
spare ones I could give to friends of
the recipients I certainly will not be
touching this top with my fingers we
will be eating today William butter
tarts a butter tart oh they are quite
popular here
we're also going to try and solve the
debate of uh should butter tarts include
or not include raisins
no no says a lot of the artists what
what we have been hearing it brings home
some strong emotion and toronturians
derision in the audience what we have
been hearing unfortunately and this
seems quite ageist but we're going to
explore it is older people eat butter
tarts with raisins and the younger
cooler set just reject the whole reason
experience so what is that anything to
do with fiber do you think possibly
fiber yeah to help the movement the path
of the Taps yes now I hear you I'm gonna
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do this why
don't you cut these things up yeah and
I'll here I'll do a little bit of a
blurb right from the start tell us about
the butter Tower the butter the basic
recipe is simple flaky Pastry as you can
see bills in a tart shape sugar egg
syrup and butter it's then baked and
gets a crunchy top carbon add-ins are
pecans the controversial raisin shredded
coconut and then in Brackets it says
here don't ever add shredded coconut
ever
strong feelings there was that Johnny
quiz possibly there are twists on the
butter like the bacon butter tar
interesting become a flavor another
dessert such as butter tar ice cream
butter cheesecake in my opinion just a
simple nothing fancy butter tar is the
best butter tart but do as you wish I'm
guessing it would be good with a lovely
cup of tea as well right oh I could go
with that right now being a big thing in
Canada in the same way that it is in
Britain that's that's cool but you guys
will kind of cut that up wow Billy
you're doing great with the whole do you
mind if I give it to some friends please
pass it around
right this one is well there's some
raisins and some non-raisins in in this
right
Billy's passing them out here
oh is that right liqueur
so it seems to be quite um versatile
this thing says according to the
Canadian encyclopedia the origin is
believed to be very old most likely the
result of the King's Daughter
trying it I guess in which approximately
800 young women were sent to Quebec from
France between 1663 and 1673 that's the
first time that they were aware of a
butter 1663.
that's crazy
um traditionally but start so maybe corn
syrup but in Algoma country where's our
Goma anyone know
oh no one knows
the favorite choice is made with syrup
or maple syrup of course
that's one of the secrets of butter
tarts in the region but if you ask for
someone's pastry recipe you'll probably
get a dirty look as most people are
secret about the way that they make
their butter tarts is that correct
William you're back
well Billy's Billy's passed out little
morsels of butter some with raisins some
without raisins now what should we try
first pills the ones with or without
doubt without
raisin which is this one
so we found out that you can there's a
butter tart liqueur yes there's a butter
cheesecake and baked ice cream yeah and
it's it's mentioned in Monty Python
isn't it is it where when
um uh a lumberjack I'm a Lumberjack and
I'm okay
and doesn't he mention a butter tart at
some point how's that yeah well let's
have a let's have a go all right here we
go
um well I mean there's a lot of Canadian
to run to run
torontonians out and the earnings is is
this the most kind of popular
cakey thing from Toronto no not really
wouldn't
is a pecan pie a big thing here because
the whole maple syrup thing yeah
um
well it comes apart in your mouth quite
quickly doesn't it yeah a disintegrate
well that's quite it's quite yummy I
like it let's try the one with raisins I
like erasing do you know the difference
between a raisin and a Sultana hold on
let me think about that though is that a
white grape and a red green I think it
is yeah well done I think a sultan the
things you learned at the Friendship
onion
I like sultanas normally I don't like
them in innocent
I'll eat them by the handful which are
very good by the way if you need to go
up and pee during the night a handful of
raisins before you go to bed don't know
why but there you go oh another one of
the raisins and there's a point in it
like those little babies over there
there's a point where for those little
babies at some point raisins are like
the greatest thing ever have you seen
little kids with raisins at some point
in their life they go absolutely ape
[ __ ] about
and then you go through a period of your
life where you're not into them and then
I think coming towards the end of your
life you're like I'm back to Roses again
and that's how you know yeah when you're
getting near the end yeah
we come full circle I have to well the
good news is yeah I don't like the
reason oh I quite like them
well
that puts another flavor in it that
doesn't need to be there oh no don't
okay no have you ever had a curry in
this Tech reasons no no what's the
reason doing in a curry rock for me I
don't like you like that oh no
good things and curries and onions and
potatoes are potato in the Korea
he's in Dunedin there it's as if it's
falling off the shelf or something
I like fresh fresh coriander on top of
my Curry well I love a curry don't worry
about that Tom but not a reason what
about because there's no reason for
reasons
get that on a t-shirt
what about we could we could answer this
kind of controversial question uh Here
and Now how do you feel about
pineapples on a pizza
let's see what Billy says and then we'll
see what the audience says now that's a
no that's a no for me no for Billy
uh how many people in the audience are a
no
it's who's that how many yes then how
many yes
wow
so yes for me I love pineapples love I
love pineapples on a pizza I'm always
defending that I think it's really
ah and you guys do the the Canadian ham
with the pineapple thing it's a Canadian
invention is it really
[Music]
was that right
wow so when people are like in a party
and you're arguing about like who's the
best country and I'm like yeah we
invented Penicillin and and the light
bulb and
and the refrigerator and you can go away
hold on now hold on to your bills there
big man
pineapples on the pizza thank you on a
pizza it gets cold in Canada we think
out the box
hey Dom without reasons that is
fantastic what's reasons it's an
absolute disgrace no I I
like I like both versions and I'm not
sure um how's it going to market then
how are we going to get the scores let's
give it scores out of um what now what
we're doing we're gonna have to assess
that's two different things I think so
we're gonna have to give it quick scores
then all right with let's do all of it
without raisins first all right so taste
without raisins 9.5 absolutely delicious
yeah fluffy pastry I don't know what
that is inside it do you know what that
is inside what is inside the what is
that Welsh a what sugar eggs
[Music]
Nutella Nutella you say oh we've still
yet to do that on the podcast oh
love it
um all right I I thought it was all
right I'm not crazy about it maybe with
a cup of tea it would get better I'll
give it a an a
you don't care what what's Good As It
Gets
uh okay Carry On on your way busy off to
another panel off you go see you later
have fun
um
it's an eight for me for taste I liked
it didn't like it as much as you okay uh
the look it looks very kind of old
dickensian kind of treats like something
that you would see in Oliver Twist or A
Christmas Carol in a shop window yeah
yeah no absolutely no glamor to it but I
quite like that no one's saying look how
beautiful I made this this is how you
would have seen it in 1673 let me
imagine it oh that's what I would have
said so I I like the look I like the
Simplicity I'm going to give it a nine
yeah I do as well I'll give it a name
and then your favorite category which
you invented yourself usefulness how
useful is that we've already found out
that there's a um there's a butter tart
liqueur wow that's lovely you can have
it as an ice cream flavor you can have
it as cheesecake
yeah it's pretty possible I think it's
good I think
I think it's quite interesting
it's an 8.5 for me you can what
see yeah and that's always one of yours
can you stick it over a tupperware yeah
can you put it in your pocket kind of
um
it's an eight for me 7.8 I think it
probably gets the same scores apart from
taste right because the look is the same
looks the same versatility kind of the
same versatility is the same except I
don't want to put it in my mouth so
without raisins what's what's the taste
taste without raisins oh sorry with
reasons it's not a good taste I quite
liked it it's not even as if it's like
the same tasting oh there's a reason
it's different it's like the reason has
taken over
it's a 3.4 oh wow you didn't like it at
all
I'm going to give it the exact same uh
taste because I liked it so I think I
gave it an eight for the first one so
it's an eighty revisit that but it is
it's the one without raisins that wins
Without Rain absolutely yeah so without
raisins wins
tell your local bakery no more raisins
please
and go to your local Curry House and say
never put a raisin in a curry no
okay we've got we've got a couple of
minutes left should we see if we can
squeeze in one more question
one last question before the Friendship
onion leaves Toronto you pick someone
just so much pressure really well I
normally go for the first one that goes
up is that a good idea well you just a
hand up and a pointer so that right okay
the lady there with the hand up and the
man pointing hello
what's your name and where do you come
from sorry give me a question oh sorry
she must be Canadian here she comes oh
she's coming down
just to say hello well yeah thanks
hi well my name is Keisha osei and I am
from Milton Ontario Melton it's
oh
it's like
lazy and I don't drive just yet and so
it's like a hour and a half bus all
right that's a long time
you want a butter or not I'll survive
yeah you'll be okay I've done all my
fair share of customer service jobs I'll
be fine you've made it
uh well to start off uh I just graduated
from journalism and so I have this pipe
dream of becoming an entertainment
journalist and interviewing people like
you oh cool and so my question forgive
the shakes very big moment uh what is a
question that you wish journalists would
stop asking
also spotting all sporting some Lord of
the Rings kind of either like that
here's a weird one a journalist asked me
once and I'm not saying I wish they
would stop asking because no one has
ever asked me it since okay
The Fellowship of the Ring came out and
we did so much press like you wouldn't
believe
days and days all over the world
six minute four minute interviews just
like all day so you're hearing the same
thing all day every day we got to France
when the two towers came out and this
this this journalist said to me
so we've seen The Fellowship of the Ring
and you played Pippin who do you play in
this movie oh
I was like
I'm so sorry
crazy yeah so that that has that one
always stuck my mind because I didn't I
couldn't get any it has mate you know
when something happens and you can kind
of jump into someone else's mind and
what the hell happened right because
it's senior I don't know Flatline
absolute Flatline brilliant yeah I think
like Billy said I think in terms of like
an original question that just really
kind of made you a bit flummoxed as to
how to answer it um and this might have
been Lost in Translation but in Japan
someone asked it was Elijah and myself
uh what is The Melody of your character
and I was just I was struggling to get
clarification I think it was a Lost in
Translation that's kind of deep I
answered D Minor
that was pretty good yeah lovely it's
not just a bulky yeah and then I think
probably the ones that the one that
seems to make me kind of go Ah that's a
bit strange of a question is if you
could play another character in the
project who would you play because from
an actor's point of view I I think you
you struggle then to to not sound in
some way offensive because you're either
negating the work that you've done
saying well I would have much preferred
to play this character or what you might
be alluding to saying is I think there's
a chance that I would have done what
they did differently or made different
choices which you know you don't want to
really do that either it feels a little
is slightly lazy question I think from a
journalist just like Charlie Hunnam said
the same thing like do the work for us
you're like well you know there's so
many things to ask and just like if you
could switch roles it seems just a
little lame so that would be my one well
thank you both so much thank you thank
you I hope it goes great we look forward
to being interviewed by you at some
point in the future
hey Billy we've run out of time guys
that was a lot of fun thank you for so
much fun uh we will hope to do some more
of these we're going to hope to do a few
more live podcasts next year and maybe
Billy and I were just saying we might
not even have it be attached to a
convention we might just end up coming
to cities and doing theater shows and
stuff like that so thank you so much for
your support thank you for seeing so
much of the merchandise out there it's
so great to see you we say it so many
times there's no way that we can make
this podcast if it didn't mean that you
guys were subscribing and helping us out
so we very much appreciate thank you for
coming we'll see you around thank you
thank you for coming to the Friendship
onion bye
[Music]
harmonize with me
[Music]